[Music]
it's being called a breakthrough for
poorer countries after two weeks of
talks nearly 200 Nations agreed to
establish a fund to compensate those
most at risk from climate change
delegates at the cop 27 conference in
Egypt's most famous Coastal Resort
ratified the Declaration in the early
hours on Sunday we heard the calls and
we responded
today here in Sharma Sheikh we
established the first ever dedicated
fund for loss and damage a farm that has
been so long in the making
it is a huge achievement
get an agreement to establish loss and
damage fund
small island States vulnerable countries
developing countries trying to get this
on the agenda
negotiators still have to hammer at
details and no decisions been made on
where the money will come from nor how
grants will be distributed but delegates
from low-income countries say they're
optimistic excited very very excited
this is a very positive result from
1.3 billion Africans yes
very very exciting because they for us
success
in Egypt was going to be based on what
we get from Los Angeles yet a warning
from the U.N Secretary General he says
the fund alone isn't enough to prevent
climate catastrophes but it's not an
answer if the climate crisis washes a
small island State off the map or turns
an entire African country to Desert
a prospect many hoped would be addressed
through a stronger commitment to
limiting Global heating to 1.5 degrees
Celsius but that didn't happen that's
despite the target being seen by many as
the minimum temperature rise that would
prevent the worst impacts of climate
change Barbara angopa Al Jazeera